And it's like, what am I going to
do? Biceps and chest. It's over.
Hey Dude, to 25 ever again. Yeah.
That was my workout since I was like
18. I'd go in, nothing. Nothing changed.
It was two 25 years.
And then let's do some curls and a,
you know, neglect the abs
and go home. The legs,
no legs. Although I did have
a, I played soccer growing
up, so I did have those, uh,
soccer lakes.
I got like Earl Campbell thighs.
Yeah, soccer is one of the
best exercises ever. I mean,
it was also a great way to blow your
ACL out. Totally. Everybody's, you know,
it's shifting left and right and all
that. There's a fucking picture, you know,
big boy, the a, the a,
the Dj, his fucking son.
There's a video.
He retweeted it.
His son is a football
player and there's a,
there's a video of his son where,
you know,
someone's trying to tackle him
and he moves like a fucking ghost.
It's incredible.
You watch him like it was one,
one of those rare things where you see
something and you're like legitimately
impressed. Like, Holy Shit, I
watched it like five times in a row.
This kid's footwork is incredible.
Yeah. But footwork like that,
kind of like, like who's in
better shape than soccer players?
They're constantly sprinting dog games
like you and you have to maintain that
stamina.
You're constantly sprinting.
There's a lot of mileage you're
putting on in a, in a soccer game.
Although you know what
gives me and you're, you're,
you are probably going to laugh as
well as your listeners. Believe me.
Pickleball, you ever played pickle
ball? What does that pickle pickle ball.
It's like pennys and pink Pong.
And you played in a gymnasium. So
it's like a, it's a net and it's,
you got paddles and talk about
moving side to side. It's,
it's fun and you burn a ton of
calories and you do it in a gym.
You didn't have an gym and like a,
like a basketball court.
So it's like racquetball, but
there's a net, there's a net.
So it's a bouncing off the wall. You're,
you plan it like tennis. It's, yeah,
it's a court, small net. And you have, uh,
like in Venice, those little
small courts. It why of old.
Hello, my name is Fred. This is, listen,
you're going to laugh. All right.
There's a lot of old people that
play this, but I'm telling you it's,
this is embarrassing. So you each
have your use for people. Yeah,
you could do doubles,
but me and my buddy play just one
on one and I'm telling you it's not,
it looks like it's not only fun,
but you,
you burn a lot of calories and you don't
even know you're doing it because I'm
diving and it's, uh, it's one
of the exercises that we, uh,
we really enjoy it when he's got you
doing and he's got you doing polities
pickle ball. What's next? I have no,
he's working his way. He know what he's
working towards. I don't have to tell him.
I'll call you. I know a lot of 68
year old people play this, but, uh,
if you're looking for a low, uh,
kind of impact, fun activity,
uh, it looks good if you're
looking at it and go, oh, it does.
Tennis is fucking hard. And it's man,
it's another thing. This is like a,
this is like tennis reduced
to a smaller court basically.
Probably Healthier for you. It's not
as hard on the ankles and the needs to,
it's not as hard.
I will have to go after we have our steak,
we would one go to him.
And of course in Venice beach.
That's what I thought it was.
I've always seen these small tennis
courts there and I know really what people
were playing. So they're calling it
paddle tennis. Yeah. Maybe. Maybe this,
but this is what, this is what it
is. These guys look ridiculous.
They should just go home. This is
outrageous. What are you doing sir?
I'm telling you. Put a little
English. Listen, I grew up ping pong.
I'm really good at Ping Pong.
Yeah.
So this is like a larger
version of ping pong.
Yeah. It looks like it's fun. All bullshit
aside. That looks like a good time.
It's fun. Believe me, I know your
listeners at night and left and right now,
but I'm telling you it's,
it's uh, it's, it's good.
So that's what I'm doing.
Show.
So you take your trainer with you on
your road on the road. That's the move.
Where's this? Where'd you meet this
guy? I've known him for 20 years.
I met him on the set of days of our lives,
doing extra work days of our lives.
When I first came out to la in 1998,
I was the type of guy,
I would do these weird like
mailings to get work right.
So for days of our lives, not, gee, it
was general hospital, General Hospital,
take a headshot and then
take a post it note.
And I would write on the post
it note ready to operate,
stuck it could had shot and I sat it out.
So I would do these like weird
little mailing. Oh, you know,
maybe the personal opened
in the mail would go, oh,
I get a little chuckle and whatnot.
So I met him doing extra work.
This is what I used to do, uh,
for, for some extra cash. And uh,
we became fast friends.
He's an Italian kid and uh,
w w w similar upbringing, middle class.
He's from New York. I'm from Chicago.
And, uh, just a great, great guy.